thank you for joining us we begin with
breaking news out of Nigeria where at
least 100 people appeared dead after a
boat capsized it happened on the Niger
River between Niger and kwara States
Witnesses say the vessel was carrying
people returning from a wedding ceremony
in Niger State let's go live to Al
jazeera's a mediteris who is in Abuja
for us Ahmed what more are you hearing
about the circumstances of this accident
well basically we hear that search and
rescue is still going on but it's with
more than 24 hours past now since that
accident we're probably looking at a
recovery effort now the situation
according to Witnesses we've spoken with
looks grim and people are thrown into
mourning and most of the victims are
coming from two villages in kwara state
they went into Niger state for a wedding
and were coming back when their boat hit
something in in the water and then
capsized and we understand that the boat
was overloaded hundreds were on that
boat the officials are still struggling
to get as much information as they can
and the accident happened in a remote
location far away from the state capital
where the police are the police have
confirmed that the accident happened but
they can't say exactly how many people
have died but what we're hearing from
now from various sources in that area is
that at least 64 people came from one
Village and about 40 from another
Village and so the incident is uh still
this story is still developing in that
area such and rescue as we said is going
on but again it's looking increasingly
like a recovery effort so a developing
story as you say I made such accidents
sadly and not unusual in Nigeria what's
being done to improve safety
well basically let's look at the courses
first of all Folly the river Niger and
the other River in Nigeria the two main
rivers River benue are all silted there
is huge deposit of sand and debris in
that air in in those rivers and these
have built up over the years there is no
dredging over time and so there are
islands in in the two rivers trees have
grown there and again we see
recklessness on the part of owners of
these boats overcrowding is one of the
causes of these accidents and of course
lack of Regulation and most of most
especially on these boats you hardly
find a PPE like personal protective
equipment like live vest so people are
just risking their life because of lack
of access roads to go onto these boats
to either go to farm or to visit
relations elsewhere or even go to
hospitals and so those these are some of
the main reasons why we have these
frequent accidents on the two main
rivers in Nigeria last year we had a
terrible incidents in neighboring Niger
state in July in October and in December
hundreds of people died in the Riven on
the river Niger and so the story is the
same in cabi state as well which is also
on the river Niger which uh also lost a
lot of people because of such accidents
in the last year Ahmed thank you very
much for bringing us the latest there
from Nigeria we'll keep a close eye of
course on that developing story and
update you here on Al Jazeera as and
when we have more information thank you